well you can say that iron is in my
blood it's in your blood as well it's
iron that gives hemoglobin the red
pigment in your blood it's red color it
is an absolutely central molecule to
element to life except for crabs which
use copper but you'll have to hear about
that later so iron ions is really really
abundant metal which is used as lots of
lots of structural material so you can
see lots of pieces of iron around some
of the racking and even facts some of
these pieces of equipment have got high
iron content they've got other elements
mixed with them to form alloys like
stainless steel or perhaps Hastelloy so
there might be some nickels and chromium
but you can see some really quite
wonderful iron components here but if we
perhaps go across throughout draw I have
an extremely long-standing interest in
its chemistry and particular I made one
compound of iron so called iron tetra
carbonyl which had four groups around it
and everybody had expected that it would
have a shape like one of these shaped
with tetrahedron like that whereas in
fact it turned out that it had a much
more irregular shape the four groups
were arranged like this and so ever
since this every time mates hear the
word iron and get quite excited so here
we have the iron sponge and if we rotate
the glass we can see that flows a bit
like a liquid you really really find the
VAT divided powder and that would be
made by a precipitation method or
something like that
okay so I'll pop that back in the box
let's see what are the pieces of iron
that we can find so this is iron wire
okay and you can see this is a very
small wire it's point two of a
millimeter in diameter and you can see
the the shiny material underneath is
iron that hasn't undergone oxidation so
this is where it's been protected from
the oxygen in the air now if we look at
the iron at the top we can see this
looks really familiar especially because
it looks like the rust that we might
find on the bottom side of some of our
cars so here's some iron oxide on top of
the iron the very first chemical
experiment I did was what chemical
reaction was with
I earn and I think the same is true for
many generations of school children i
heated their iron and sulfur together
and made iron sulfide little blackish
solid but then we put acid on it and got
a terrible smell of bad eggs and this
was my introduction to chemistry and I
really loved it